the parents of one of our Kelly's
live-in girlfriends are talking with us
Timothy and John Dylan savage accused
Kelly of brainwashing and abusing their
23 year old daughter Joycelyn Kelly
denies all allegations he and Joycelyn
say the savages are looking for money
which they deny there has never been any
financial transaction between you and
our Kelly let me make sure I'm clear
mm-hmm
never receive any funds from our Kelly
have you asked for how never ask for any
monies from our Kelly only thing I've
asked Mark Kelly is one thing to see my
daughter and make sure she's healthy and
fine I'm gonna do everything in my power
to get her evaluated and to proper
therapy that she would need to be
rehabilitation of this because I know my
daughter do you know your daughter
I knew her three plus years ago but the
Josslyn now that I see is not my
daughter the savages say they hope Kelly
would help Joycelyn build a singing
career she denies any interest of that
but her parents say go online she loves
to sing despite years of sexual
misconduct allegations against Kelly the
savages say they felt comfortable
working with him because he was
acquitted of child pornography charges
back in 2008 they say they quote
separated the artist from the man and
did not realize then what they know now
and just think about this for a second I
asked Tim savage how old he is he's 45
our Kelly is 52 so she is dating someone
who was older than her father father
needless to say that is very troubling
to them as well you can hear more from
our interviews with as we elk Larry and
Jocelyn Joycelyn rather savage
Jonathan's parents and our Kelly in a
prime-time special it starts tonight at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS